are you ever worried about making the
transition over to adult roles or are
you satisfied with people have asked me
that but you know my answer is I'll tell
you what my answer is would you like to
know my answer is that um
I'll never get to really be young again
and this is my time to be young
so if there's roles right now that fit
me as a young person
I'm gonna do them and not sort of rush
into becoming the young adult I am a
young adult but like to be like the you
know
sex symbol or this you know the young
guy
if I can do roles right now that are
young I'll never get a chance to do them
again and I plan on being around for a
while so
I'll get to do all that stuff later in
life